late last week Donald Trump issued an
executive order creating the
Presidential Commission on election
integrity this is a this is an office
that is going to try to fight against
voter fraud which of course doesn't
exist looking to solve a problem that
does not exist for people in 2016 were
caught committing voter fraud three of
those people were Republicans who
presumably voted for Trump there were 31
cases of voter impersonation from 2000
to 2014 the reality about so-called
voter fraud investigations and
legislation is that it's a way to
suppress Democratic and minority votes
remember Donald Trump has a lot of ego
riding on this he tweeted as I'm sure
you remember in addition to winning the
electoral college in a landslide I won
the popular vote if you deduct the
millions of people who voted illegally
now Trump's own lawyers have said
there's actually no evidence of
significant voter fraud from the 2016
presidential election not only is that
based on Trump's debunked claims that
quote millions voted illegally in the
election the two people that Trump has
put in charge of this commission have
horrible track records of suppressing
voter turnout who's running this
abortion of a commission while Mike
Pence is going to be the chair in
October of 2016
it's what 2016 underpins the indiana
state police raided the office of a
group that helped black and low-income
people register to vote they were
originally suspected of forging voter
registration forms no one has been
charged because it was discovered that
the suspicions were because they were
comparing the groups forms to outdated
state voter rolls I mean just bogus okay
pence cheered the entire investigation
and then this is where we really get
into the thick of it the vice-chair of
this commission on election integrity is
going to be none other than I hope
you're sitting down Kansas secretary of
state Kris Kobach who has been sued by
the ACLU for voter suppression not once
not twice not three times but four times
and has lost those
lawsuits to the ACLU not once not twice
not three times but all four times Co
Bach is the person that the White House
has cited when addressing Trump's
unproven voter fraud claims this is a
closed loop of logic right Trump says
three to five million people voted
illegally really well where'd you get
that information Oh Kris Kobach is a
believes that we're right oh really the
guy who works for you and himself has a
long track record of suppressing voter
turnout we could not first of all we
could not be solving a problem that was
less of a problem in this one and we
could not have worse people trying to
solve the non-existent problem and
always to believe that had Donald Trump
won the popular vote by three million
instead of losing it by three million
that he'd still be on this topic it
really just looks as if he's trying to
find people that will agree with them
Republicans in Congress won't agree with
them as own lawyers won't so if it means
using government resources to create a
commission and find the right guy he'll
do it and if it works right if co Bach
is able to influence for a federal
policy on this so that enough voter ID
rule rules are implemented think of the
voter suppression that this will lead to
it would result in a systemic change on
a national scale
Kobach has already called for the
National Voter Registration Act to be
amended to require people to provide
proof of citizenship to register to vote
again it's not about wanting
non-citizens to vote it's that showing
proof of citizenship requires documents
that if you don't have and many people
don't you have to pay to obtain in the
past
Trump has consulted Kovac about the
Muslim ban about a Muslim registry about
the border wall about mass deportations
Kobuk clearly has Trump's ear and that's
really scary and all of this especially
who Trump chooses to lead this effort
it's all a sign that voter suppression
is a goal of this commission it's it's
or this is Orwellian a lot of things
we've talked about are not so much
Orwellian but more reminiscent of brave
new world by Aldous Huxley this is
straight-up Orwellian the idea of a
president election integrity commission
that
actually is going to try to suppress the
vote this is very scary stuff and
obviously the integrity of our elections
is very important so that's why maybe
it's not a great idea to potentially
collude with the Russians or a foreign
agency to get you elected also it's why
we need to update the system of electing
these officials so things like the
Electoral College don't exist anymore
there are ways there are systemic ways
you can modify how we do elections and
this goes at the local level and this
goes all the way up to the federal level
as pat is talking about but none of
these are on the horizon again when you
have a party that benefits from fewer
people voting why on earth would they
allow the system to be changed to get
more people to vote they don't want more
people to vote kind of a weird thing in
a representative democracy you would
want it to be representative of as many
people as possible but I guess not